en el vídeo de depreciación estábamos
platicando que si una compañía tenía que
comprar un equipo para su fábrica
digamos al principio de 2007 entonces
nada más basándonos en el efectivo que
se gastó pues podríamos tener la
tentación de decir ok en 2007 tuvimos un
no sé digamos gasto de equipo gasto de
equipo de 50 mil pesos o sea esos 50 mil
pesos los escribimos todos en el 2007
entonces aquí pondrían menos 50 mil
bueno a lo mejor podrían compositivo yo
le pongo con negativo para acordarme que
es un gasto o sea que es algo que le
resta dinero al ingreso va porque
entonces lo voy a poner con negativo
bueno entonces pues pondrían ese gasto
todo ese gasto ahí en 2007 y luego en
años futuros no sé digamos en 2008 en
2009 en 2010 en esos años no tendría
ningún gasto hasta que no se tenga que
reemplazar el equipo o comprar uno nuevo
bueno supongo que esa es una forma en la
cual se puede hacer la contabilidad pero
no refleja la realidad del negocio el
hecho de que esta máquina
250 mil pesos se usa por bueno no sé en
el ejemplo pasado era por dos años
digamos que en este ejemplo va a ser por
cuatro años ok entonces en vez de hacer
esto en vez de simplemente poner el
costo de la máquina cuando la máquina se
compra en la hoja de balance al
principio de 2007 vamos a poner que
tenemos un activo ahora tenemos un
activo que se llama máquina le voy a
poner m por máquina y que vale 50 mil
pesos nada raro hasta aquí ojo es en
esta altura es antes de 2007 cuando
compramos el equipo recuerda que las
hojas de balance son sólo fotografías
entonces en vez de poner el gasto el
gasto por el equipo vamos a poner otro
concepto que es depreciación de equipo
voy a poner aquí depreciación de equipo
la diferencia es que en vez de decir en
vez de poner todo el gasto en el primer
período
decimos no sabes que estamos usando
solamente una parte de la máquina en ese
período vamos a hacer una depreciación
en línea lo cual básicamente quiere
decir que despreciamos este activo de
manera equitativa en el transcurso de
todo su vida útil
acaso nos estamos suponiendo que es de
cuatro años y entonces el valor del
activo debería de disminuir linealmente
en el transcurso de ese tiempo bueno
vamos a hacer las cuentas del gasto
entonces en el primer año nuestro gasto
sería cuánto pues 50.000 dividido entre
4 es 12 mil 500 entonces sería menos
12.500
menos 12.500 cada año verdad menos
12.500 menos 12.500 en gastos de
depreciación menos 12.500 y luego
tendríamos que registrar eso en la hoja
de balance porque recuerda los estados
de resultados nada más nos dicen cómo
pasamos de una hoja de balance a otra y
entonces los gastos lo que hacen es
reducir el valor retroactivo y por
ejemplo al principio de aquí antes de
que pasara 2007 verdad teníamos que la
máquina valía 50 mil pesos pero después
al despreciar las 12 mil 500 pesos
después cuando se acabe el 2007 verdad
hubo al principio de 2008 vamos a tener
que la máquina la máquina ahora vale 12
mil 500 menos o sea 47 mil 500 pesos
luego al final de 2008 y principios de
2009 la hoja de balance en la parte de
activos diría que la máquina valdría 12
mil 500 menos entonces nos quedaría 35
mil la máquina valdría 30 perdón esto de
acá es 37 mil 500 entonces aquí dos mil
500 menos es 20
25 mil pesos luego al disminuir otros 12
mil 500 pesos la máquina queda que vale
2 en 1500 y al final de 2010 la máquina
ya no va a valer nada si hicimos nuestro
esquema de depreciación bien y la vida
útil de esta máquina realmente es cuatro
años entonces es hora de comprar otra
máquina y volver a hacer el esquema de
depreciación bueno esto es nada más un
repaso amortización es exactamente lo
mismo pero ahora tiene que ver con la
activo intangible que es un activo
intangible pues es algo que no puedes
ver tocar sentir oler comer bueno a lo
mejor con una máquina no puedes hacer
todas estas cosas pero al menos puedes
tocarla o leerla y pues tal vez probarla
por otro lado un activo intangible es al
cual no le puedes hacer ninguna de esas
cosas pero la idea es básicamente la
misma por ejemplo supongamos que es otra
vez somos una compañía de artesanías y
déjame escribir los años 2007
8 2009 y 2010 ok y supongamos que desde
un punto de vista de efectivo no sé
supongamos que compramos un patente para
hacer las artesanías más eficientemente
entonces podríamos decir sabes que
tuvimos un gasto de patente que le
pagamos a un inventor así bien brillante
que nos va a acelerar mucho la
producción entonces tuvimos un gasto de
patente en 2007 de 4 mil pesos aunque
esté patente podría tener una vida útil
de no sé cuatro años entonces esta forma
de llevar la contabilidad no refleja el
hecho de que el patente lo podemos usar
por cuatro años registra un gasto enorme
que da la apariencia de un ingreso
inusualmente bajo y en estos otros años
registra un ingreso inusualmente alto de
esta forma de llevar la contabilidad no
registra el hecho de que estamos usando
el patente por cuatro años
bueno en vez de hacer eso lo que vamos a
hacer es que en el primer periodo al
adquirir el patente le vamos a poner que
adquirimos un activo de cuatro mil pesos
y luego en el transcurso de la vida útil
del patente lo que vamos a hacer es
amortizar un cuarto de ese gasto
entonces tendríamos un gasto que se
llama amortización de patente de patente
y hay un montón de activos intangibles
que podrías amortizar amortizar
realmente ese es dividir el costo de un
activo intangible justo como depreciar
es dividir el costo de uno que es
tangible entonces en la amortización
aquí sería de mil pesos menos mil
también acá otros menos mil y finalmente
menos mil ok y entonces nuestras
nuestras fotografías nuestras hojas de
balances digamos al final de 2007 el
patente diría que valdría tres mil pesos
al final de 2008 serían mil pesos menos
o sea dos mil pesos y al final de 2009
creo que es la idea verdad el patente
valdría mil al final de cuatro años al
final de 2010 como el patente ya expiró
y ahora cualquiera puede hacer
artesanías tan eficientemente como
nosotros verdad como cualquiera puede
utilizar la tecnología sin tener el
patente el patente ya no vale nada ahora
esto de los patentes
relevante para las compañías
farmacéuticas comprando un patente para
hacer una medicina exclusivamente no sé
digamos por cuatro años pero luego
cuando se expira cuando ya pasaron los
cuatro años cualquiera puede hacerlas y
entonces el patente ya no vale nada
entonces la hoja de balance lo que
realmente está reflejando es cuánto vale
el activo en el transcurso del tiempo en
este punto en el tiempo ya nada más vale
mil porque pagamos cuatro mil por cuatro
años y ya nada más queda uno bueno eso
es amortización como puedes ver no es
nada sofisticado déjame escribirlo
bonito a amortización y bueno como yo lo
pienso es que es muy similar a
depreciación depreciación es tangible
amortizaciones intangibles puede ser
patentes puede ser licencias o pueden
ser costos asociados con financiamiento
por ejemplo que quieres deuda de una
compañía y la deuda va a ser por diez
años y no sea al principio tuviste que
pagar una gran cantidad al banco
entonces esa gran cantidad la puedes
repartir en los diez años de duración de
deuda y entonces la estarías amortizando
bueno esto es todo lo que te quería
platicar ahorita nos vemos